this is just the best I think you're
gonna like this one for all of the
attacks on the infamous Trump Russia
dossier by Christopher steel steel has
now come out on top
in a libel case against him in court
Trump claimed the entire dossier was
fake his defenders claimed it was just
made up lies and it has now been upheld
as at least not libelous or defamatory
in a court of law
Christopher Steele is a former mi6
officer the UK's Intelligence Service
and he won a case in the United States
against three Russian oligarchs who sued
him because the oligarch said the stuff
that Christopher Steele put in the Trump
Russia dossier about them about us they
said was untrue it's defamatory it's
libelous and the court decided that no
that's not the case Christopher Steele
said that the case should be thrown out
and a judge agreed the judge didn't
decide are the contents accurate line by
line are they true or untrue but what
the judge did decide was that the
document the steel dossier was not
deliberately inaccurate which is the
standard that's applied to what Steele
put in it when you're trying to figure
out whether it's defamatory or libelous
so this tells us that as far as a judge
is concerned whether or not every claim
in the dossier is true it's not a
dossier put together with unsourced
knowingly false material like close to
Christopher steel it contains claims of
varying specificity you could argue it
contains it contains claims of varying
accuracy because it's a report of what
Steele's sources told him but it was put
together in a way that a court decided
is simply not defamatory now the Russian
oligarchs aren't pleased they said they
would quote almost certainly appeal the
court's decision it's not hugely likely
that it would go a different way on
appeal and steel is still up against
libel charges in the UK there's another
Russian named Alexei Gubarev who's named
in the dossier and he's going to have to
deal with that in the UK but this is yet
another good result I would say for the
dossier now Trump
will hear me and they'll say David this
doesn't prove the accuracy of anything
in the dossier and that's true I'm not
trying to hide that much of the dossier
has been separately corroborated but
what this decision does mean is that the
allegations about the Russians who sued
steel are beyond libel it's a win for
the legitimacy of elements of the
dossier as genuine reports of what
people told steel and I feel like that's
what's missing from the conversation Pat
people say steel made this stuff up or
Steel's not trustworthy or or he
concocted this stuff or not and we need
to punish steel for making things up
steel never claimed that these were his
assertions what Christopher steel did is
he gathered information from sources
about Donald Trump who was orchestrating
that and who wanted the document put
together people like to debate that he
was not just writing stuff down he was
documenting the claims made about Donald
Trump it was not a document where steel
purported to adjudicate what was true
and what wasn't true and and hopefully
that gets figured out as cases are
decided that they are not defamatory on
that basis yeah I feel like the claims
made by steel seem just so outrageous
when they were first released yeah
because you know this was their first
time looking at these allegations and
and people that just kind of stuck with
people right that there is no way that
the Trump PP tape exists and that all of
the Trump associates were this involved
in Russia yeah and you know it's kind of
hard to come back from that no way and
when we actually look at the reality
that more and more elements of the
dossier have been independently
corroborated over time we now have
Michael Cohen who supposedly had nothing
to do with anything he has now pled
guilty to eight counts although not
directly related to the contents of the
dossier but it's all now fitting
together so it's really important that
you not fall for Trump is saying it's
meaningless because it doesn't prove the
truth of the claims in the dossier the
story is that the people that were
claiming that what Steele wrote about
them was defamatory were able to present
no evidence
that the contents were untrue and
certainly not that the contents were
defamatory and the judge threw the case
out so it's definitely not phony it's
definitely not been discredited as what
was it that Carter page called it on the
show that dodgy dasya what we have is a
list of assertions more of which have
been independently corroborated now than
at any previous time and I think it
would actually be very interesting to go
back to the dossier and go through it
point by point now pulling out the parts
that have been separately corroborated
at this point it's quite a few and that
might actually be useful for the
audience to see us do and maybe we will
do that sometime soon